a handful of kid vid writers have taken
it upon themselves to close out their
series with some spectacularly
definitive and dark final episodes
here's a look at some of the darkest
series finales of kids TV shows Superman
the animated series the finale of
Superman the animated series find
Superman going full evil but it's not
his fault as Darkseid has brainwashed
him into unleashing death and
destruction after Superman attacks some
military bases
Supergirl tries to stop him and nearly
gets killed in the process
which is when Lois Lane shows up and
breaks the trance later on Superman
awakens in a military prison awaiting
execution but he manages to escape and
make his way back to Darkseid's palace
for a final extremely violent
confrontation
Superman nearly kills the bad guy but
instead he implores Darkseid's oppressed
followers to do with him what they wish
forever devoted they whisk his body away
from medical treatments as for Superman
he has to deal with a planet full of
people who feel betrayed by their
one-time protector unaware of the
brainwashing and apocalypse the world of
David the known one of the original Nick
jr. cartoons the world of David the
gnome was a gentle show about magical
creatures and forest animals this richly
animated series followed around tiny
impressively bearded David and his known
family and friends as he went about his
quiet gnome life according to lore
gnomes lived to the age of 404 the run
of the show David and his wife Lisa were
right around 399 and so on the series
finale death came for David Lisa and
another gnome named Casper or rather
they came for death doing what 400 year
old gnomes do they ritualistically
accepted their fate
walking to the aptly named mountain of
beyond where they transformed into trees
[Music]
my Tmax a pocket-sized toy line of
action figures and playsets called
mighty max reach stores in 1992 a year
later the mighty max TV series hit the
air adding a surprisingly rich backstory
and mythology to those cheap pieces of
plastic
it begins with max receiving a statue
that contains an ancient teleportation
and a baleen baseball cap that also
leads him to do battle with a hideous
monster called the skull master mighty
max was one of the most violent kid
shows of the era as the skull master
routinely and graphically killed people
in the final episode he even kills Max's
friends a prophetic foul named Virgil
and a Viking named Norman so max uses
his face ball cap to travel back in time
to the events of the first episode he
then goes forth to relive the entire
series only with an eye this time toward
an outcome where his best friends don't
die all over again
reboot imagine if you will a time in
which children were not computer savvy
and we needed semi educational TV shows
to familiarize them with the basic
technology that time was the 1990s a
period in which ABC's Saturday morning
lineup included a show called reboot set
inside a computer city called mainframe
the action involved a guardian named Bob
who protected the city against viruses
named hexadecimal and megabyte reboot
could be a little corny at times but are
also demystified computing terms for
millions of tech minded kids many of
those same kids were likely traumatized
by the surprisingly dark ending
megabytes in the form of a Trojan horse
virus gains access to the good guys lair
and sets out to infect every program in
existence in other words he destroys the
world of the show and the heroes don't
know how to stop it
prepare yourselves
for the heart
Digimon Tamers part of the Digimon
universe of cartoons and games Digimon
Tamers was a one season wonder about
cute animals that are also magical
fighting monsters trained by children on
the final episode the various Digimon
and their human companions waged war
against the evil V Reaper they prevail
sending the bad guy back into the
digital world from whence he came but it
only works because the Digimon
themselves have to get sucked into
oblivion as well one by one the cute
little guys disappear as their
heartbroken trainers look on sure the
cliffhanger seems to suggest there's
some sort of portal to that other realm
but for all intents and purposes those
Digimon are gone gone gone
[Music]